Tamara's with us in New York City hi
Tamara how are you hi babe I'm okay I'm
calling because for the last two years
I've just found myself in a lot of debt
before that I was like I think good at
saving and managing myself what I have I
had two kids in college at the same time
hmm and they didn't follow my advice
they picked very expensive schools one
of them got some scholarships and the
other one didn't get any and you
supported their bad decisions and I had
the support no you didn't have you chose
to yes but then now I have like credit
card that because I charged some of
their tuition on my credit card on the
school that they couldn't afford yeah
okay yeah so is this over this is over
are they out of school well no I just
told my son because he wasn't giving me
his grades and stuff like that I told
him I'm not gonna support your school if
that's how you're gonna behave correct
and then my daughter she feels like
because she gets for at least like 60 to
70% scholarships for her cool that like
you know the father and I should split
and pay the rest mm-hmm oh so she gets
to tell you how you're supposed to do
with your money this is a bright kid
very manipulative you shouldn't get
tellurian titles there's another
generation is very entitled know your
daughters around right yeah but I just I
don't like debt and I don't like the
financial situation I'm in and I have
like old emergency fund but it's like
every month it's like I find myself
taking $1,000 from it so it was like
about 25,000 now it's about 17 and I
have about 40,000 dollars of debt so I
was wondering if I just take that
emergency fund pay it down and there's
snowball the rest of them and start over
yes ma'am yes if and only if you learn a
new word you ready for the word no
that's the word no
can you use that work yes I'm trying no
don't try you have to do it because
here's the thing if you don't stop this
the Titanic is going to go down you you
can you can stick your finger in one
little hole but it's it's hemorrhaging
on the other end the things just
bleeding water I mean it's just
everywhere so you you know your daughter
is going to go to a school in a place
that you agree with because you can
afford to support it or she gets nothing
and the same with your son it has to fit
your budget or the answer's no you don't
get anything they don't get to tell you
what to do with your money it is not
child abuse to not support your
children's stupid decisions
that's not child abuse you're not a bad
mom and I don't care if she's 20 and she
stomps her foot and her little lip
sticks out and she has a little Fiat Oh
bless your heart I couldn't get a crap
less you don't get to make decisions
with my money and when you do with when
you make decisions that I approve of
then you have a shot at me financing
them but I am not paying for you to make
decisions that I do not approve of now
why do I not approve of them two reasons
one is it's a bad decision and I'm
smarter than you
because I'm older than you and I have
this thing called wisdom and experience
the second reason is it's my freaking
money so I get to decide where it goes
to I don't have to put up with you 20
year olds telling me where my money is
gonna go and so you've got to reset your
parenting with her and you can do that
gently and kindly you're a gentler
kinder person than I am by nature I'm a
little more in-your-face and you're
sweet but you can still be sweet and
still say no because it doesn't fit your
budget she doesn't get to tell you where
your money goes and you're not going to
endorse with your checkbook her bad
behaviors and her bad decisions
these are threatening Rises
one sorry to interrupt but one other
thing is that there's a company that is
pitching to me for my student loan debt
which that is I didn't include that in
the money in the Dead it was like they
can help me discharge the debt but just
gave them a fee of no no there's no such
thing as discharging student loan debts
unless you are home unless you're
permanently disabled and you're on the
SSI or you're dead
these are the only two ways the student
loan debts get discharged that that's a
lie that's a scam company and you stay
away from them if it's a traditional
federally insured for Sallie Mae loan
that's the answer to that so yeah you've
got to say no you got to put some
boundaries around your life and your
money and then you know how to manage
money you just have chosen not to
because these kids have been running
your life instead of you run in your
life and I'm sorry that you got there
but that's exactly what you described to
me and you can get out of this yes in
that case if you will stop the bleeding
stop the pay giving money to people that
you can't afford to give because they're
making decisions you can't afford to
support then yes you would use your
emergency fund and yes you'd get on a
tight budget and yes you would snowball
your way right through this and you can
do all of that you really can you know
exactly what to do you've just got to go
do it now it's very hard though to tell
your kids no it's very hard to tell
people that you love no even if they're
being stupid and it's just hard I mean
every one of you've got a relative I
have relatives you look at them you go
that was stupid
and you don't say it out loud but you're
just looking at them going stupid and
you know and if they come to you asking
for you to support stupid you're not
loving them by causing you by supporting
they're stupid you're actually
participating in something that's
bringing harm to them so I'm not gonna
finance something that brings harm to
people that I love why would I do that I
love them watch tough love no darling
it's just real love love that supports
something that's damaging to someone you
love is not love that's called Co
dependencies
it's different than love way different
than love it's a toxic form of
relationships all of us have some of it
at one time or another in our lives
oh it sure does get over into the money
stuff oh man oh man there you go